ses treize hommes étaient nos soldats
les soldats de la france est aujourd'hui
devenus les héros de la nation mourir en
soldats engagés contre le terrain
terrorisme islamiste n'est pas un
sacrifice comme les autres au nom du
groupe l'est républicain nous leur
rendons hommage ma famille politique a
toujours été au rendez vous pour la
lutte contre les violences conjugales
le groupe l'est républicain dès
septembre a inscrit à l'ordre du jour de
notre assemblée deux textes forts pour
protéger les femmes victimes et leurs
enfants
à l'issue du grenelle vous dites vouloir
faire du même si elle la victime au
domicile la règle c'est intéressant
voilà pourquoi nous l'avons déjà fait
dans notre proposition loi votée à
l'unanimité le 15 octobre dernier
vous voulez accélérer les mesures de
protection c'est intéressant notre
proposition votée à l'unanimité fixe à
six jours le délai de délivrance d'une
ordonnance de protection
nous avons aussi prévu l'obligation de
soins pour les violents et la
généralisation du bracelet anti
rapprochement tout cela monsieur le
premier ministre
le parlement l'a déjà fait après des
centaines d'auditions plus de dix textes
sur le sujet j'ai notamment déposer ce
10 octobre le retrait automatique de
l'autorité parentale en cas d'homicide
qui pourrait croire que les réponses à
apporter pour combattre ce fléau ont une
couleur politique pourtant la garde des
sceaux m'a même répondu ici je la cite
une telle modification risquerait de
nous exposer à une condamnation de la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme
alors monsieur le premier ministre vous
qui prétendez ne pas être dans une
position politique
vous qui parler d'unité nationale je
vous le demande
pourquoi reprendre aujourd'hui motta
moscow votre gouvernement rejeté hier ce
que je pointe aujourd'hui c'est les
contradictions entre le discours et les
actes qui sont à mon avis au coeur du
malaise agricole vous dit soutenir la
transition écologique mais rien dans
votre budget pour accompagner
significativement une modification
profonde des modes de production
vous mettez en place une interdiction
des produits phyto mais rien pour
certaines filières dans l'impasse où
parier sur la montée en gamme et vous
soutenez les accords commerciaux qui
ouvre nos marchés à des produits qui ne
répondent pas aux exigences de
production c'est madame la ministre de
la santé il est temps de prendre de soin
de ceux qui soignent votre plan santé se
veut apaiser la colère mais il ne répond
qu'à une partie du personnel soignant
certes il va apporter des avancées par
ciel mais ce n'est qu'une goutte d'eau
dans un océan
même si les infirmières les infirmiers
aides soignants sont indispensables que
comptez vous faire pour ces professions
oublié nous constatons actuellement sur
nombre de territoires industriels une
baisse d'activité nous sommes à mi
mandat à monsieur ministre kan nou
présenterez-vous enfin une politique
industrielle concrètes et ambitieuses
clair à la hauteur de ce qu attendent et
méritent nos industries le second
semestre 2010 9 est marquée par une
recrudescence des violences à mayotte
mais la situation à mayotte elle est
exceptionnelle à une situation
exceptionnelle il faut des mesures
exceptionnelles et donc elles ne sont
pas au rendez vous voici plusieurs mois
depuis le mois de septembre que je vous
demande de renforcer les effectifs
d'organiser un grenelle de la sécurité à
mayotte regroupant tous les acteurs pour
permettre de prendre conscience de la
situation
malheureusement avec toujours le même
mépris va où nous est captée parce
qu'effectivement pour vous loin de loin
des yeux loin du coeur nos objectifs à
nous était très clair c'était en effet
revalorisation n'est pas ceux des
pensions pas de baisse des retraites
réforme des régimes spéciaux mais sans
creuser le déficit et sans laisser filer
le déficit et c'est là où il ya une
différence
alors pour l'instant vous essayez de
gagner du temps parce que vous êtes
tenus par votre promesse de pas faire de
réformes paramétriques mais pour
l'instant vous gagnez du temps et désolé
de vous décevoir mais c'est toujours
aussi floue pour moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]